yeah
Wow
I'm really glad to be here and they make
me feel very welcome
because a few hours ago I said to my
wife you know I have a stroke little
while ago I said no I don't think I will
be able to talk and she said honey
you're right you're just temporarily out
of order you know when I first had my
stroke mm-hmm I could only babble and
then I worked with the speech therapist
and then I got to talk about as good as
my three-year-old granddaughter
Kelsey uh-huh but one that day I said
they killed him and quanto I said Kelsey
saved transcontinental and she couldn't
say
I left her in the dust now I speak like
a six-year-old you look fantastic - I
gotta say thank you stunning to see you
I've never met you before
and I saw you out in the hallway and
just it's it's Kurt Douglas it's a
stunning thing we would you probably
maybe saw at the top of the show we
don't get to meet many people like you
it's a real treat let me tell you one of
those as I said is that for me that that
there for impressing the Grim Reaper
definitely not no and I wouldn't I
didn't think people really watch the
show back there in the green room most
the time I go back in the green room
they're watching something else another
thing when I see when you have a stroke
you must be slowly to be understood and
I find that when I speak slowly people
listen I'm going to say something
important and you just order a
cheeseburger I just wanted a
cheeseburger but you know why when I get
excited I can't speak well and something
I will talk to Michael and he said what
that what does a Michael don't you speak
English so Michael his movie of the game
was number one this weekend
you must be very proud of the game is a
wonderful movie believe me and he is so
good
in it you know if I knew he was going to
be so famous I would have been not much
nicer to him when he would
[Applause]
he didn't have an agent ban you see kid
you gonna make a movie do you think
where we are talking about making a
movie as the matter of fact we have
never worked together
my canon i and then before i had my
stroke we're working on the script and
then I don't want my stroke and he said
well dad listen you just work with their
speech therapist and then we'll make the
movie so I said Michael why don't you
work with my speech therapist and then I
said Michael when you talk like I talk
we'll make the move
[Applause]
but seriously I'm so proud of Michael
and have any youth in there the thing
that the game it's really a wonderful
movie and I think that Michael is really
terrific man are you able to look at him
completely as an actor or is it always
part of you this just you know that that
has that fatherly pride well I always
have the fatherly pride yeah
because I think he's a much better actor
than I am and I thought I was a good
actor no really you think he's a better
actor than you yes I think so I think so
he's good but now I was afraid he was
going to agree with me then you could
have punched me out I think you're I
want to ask you like this it's a funny
story I was reading in in your book
climbing the mountain it's a it's a
you're making the movie Oscar with
Sylvester Stallone oh yes Annie and and
it's a very funny story where it's a
very physical scene you had with him I
think I think you're playing his father
isn't that correct you know I never read
the script and they act they said they
said Stallone's in and I'm not gonna
read the script will you play a cameo I
said don't was just leave if it takes
place before the title so what to read
the first five pages and I said I will
bear because I played a dying father and
he is my son but here's a gangster so he
cam comes in and I keep slapping him in
the face and I tell you I had such a
wonderful time slapping
[Applause]
what was he was he okay with that being
slapped around so much
after why is that list I stopped it I'm
getting bang crazy but he's a good guy
yeah he's a good guy I want to ask you
about about your son because we touched
on them briefly but in the book you talk
about the fact that your sons started to
criticize the way you were dressing they
wanted you to dress more Gen X is that
is that the case no I tell you - sense
something I want they said dad you dress
you look what this is you dress like
your clothes come from a geriatric
geriatrics workshop really you think the
book means do the sword and they may be
put on there and and clothes shoes I
tell you I hated it I hated it you had
never worn shoes before
no but they made you dress in the book
you're talking about it's all that kind
of really loose fitting you know the
baggy pants exactly just like a rapper
like you have bang big baggy pants like
you have a have an accident
[Laughter]
[Applause]
when I were working that mumble I'm a
book and I would be depressed you know
shows like yours are very important
because it is important to laugh to make
a joke man no matter how bad things are
thank you for that part yeah
every can relate I know no matter how
bad things come they can always be worse
so I that's why when i I think of life
climbing a mountain
everybody is climbing the mountain and
life is how you climb the mountain and
you must climb in life with a sense of
humor so any show that makes you laugh I
think is very very precious and
important oh thank you very much as I
mentioned before our Kirk Douglas
climbing the mountain and a broken
mirror and they're both in bookstores
now and I speak for Andy - this is it
was a real pleasure and a thrill to meet
you and we hope some time you come back
again and visit us but better we'll we
can't thank you enough for all the work
you've done and for being here
thank you